nadège bonjour vous êtes devant donc les
anciens locaux de charlie hebdo ce matin
est ce que on en sait un peu plus sur le
profil du principal suspect oui bah
écoutez un doha ont fait qu'il s'agirait
d'un certain ali h né au pakistan en
2002 alors il a été arrêté peu de temps
après cette attaque à la hache un dans
le quartier de bastille les vêtements en
sang alors d'après le chef du parquet
national anti terroriste il s'agirait du
principal suspect il n'était pas fiché
pour radicalisation mais pour port
d'armes prohibées en tournevis pour
lequel il aurait été interpellé il ya un
peu plus d'un mois d'après le ministère
de l'intérieur il était alors considéré
comme un mineur isolé
ce pakistanais de 18 ans avait été prise
en charge à son arrivée en france en
mais des doutes persistent toujours sur
sa réelle identité sur son âge précis
alors la question qui se pose également
est ce que cet homme a agi seul alors
effectivement doha c'est l'une des
nombreuses questions que se posent les
enquêteurs alors ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est qu'un deuxième suspect âgé de 33
ans a été arrêté également après cette
attaque
dans la soirée une perquisition a été
menée au domicile du principal suspect
est là a mené à l'interpellation de cinq
autres hommes donc il s'agirait des
colocataires du principal suspect de
l'attentât n'a pas été revendiqué et les
motivations du principal suspect demeure
jusqu'à présent méconnue alors à la
suite de cette attaque le parquet
antiterroriste elle s'est saisie du
dossier il a ouvert une enquête en
flagrance pour tentative d'assassinât en
relation avec une entreprise terroriste
et association de malfaiteurs
terroristes criminels alors voilà rappel
cette attaque à la hache à l'interview
en plein en procès des attentats de
charlie hebdo qui ont eu lieu le 13
janvier 2015
une attaque à la hache qui intervient
également quelques semaines après
seulement l'art publication des
caricatures du prophète mohamed a là une
donc de ceux de ce journal satirique de
charlie hebdo
merci beaucoup l'adage abderrazak pour
toutes ces précisions